companies which send workers to other EU
countries could be required to pay
salaries in line with local rates the EU
Commission presented a statement to mep
s on revisions to the 1996 posted
workers directive saying it needs
updating because of abuse fraud and
social dumping the practice of
undermining local market conditions by
cheap labor since a continuum casey hays
code especi media hoja de Bourgh
xenophobe d'Italia given due today e te
amooo modern a radula party p daiquiri
the angle isfahan foxy panchasayar
hadita she eco samantha uma entire
numbers have posted workers have soared
in 2014 there were almost 2 million
across the EU construction workers make
up about forty percent followed by the
farming transport and finance sectors a
tool that was intended to simply
facilitate the provision of services
across borders has become an instrument
seen by many as enabling unfair
competition and social dumping some have
expressed fears the Commission is
meddling in member states free markets
and labour regimes MEP sought to
reassure them we need to make sure that
we are defending the rights of the
workers but not by forgetting that is
the business community involved next
step in the process is for the
Commission to draft legislation to
present to Parliament for scrutiny of
the details
I